- I mean, if I was being
interrogated like that,
you'd get all my secrets.
- What secrets?
- Are you hungry?
(suspenseful music)
- He just tossed it over
the fire and it caught--
- And it just lit up.
- Is that how cats work?
- If we want to make dinner,
we need to leave in like 30 minutes.
- (bleep) it.
- Yeah, let's just get take out.
These guys are so smart.
- They're geniuses.
- Right, and like they look really nice.
- And they want to help him!
- Yeah!
Dean's like dad hot.
- His family deserves a
break at this point, right?
- Play it, play the goddamned episode.
(bleep) this guy.
He thinks he's going to go home.
- He just wants to go home
and watch Wrestle Mania.
Are you kidding me?
- No one's talking about the blood.
- Seriously!
- If he sliced her jugular,
that (bleep) would be--
- Everywhere, everywhere.
- There would be semen.
Where's the semen?
- Maybe he didn't finish.
- Oh, well.
- Did you see Jerry in
those closing arguments?
- I mean, he wasn't Dean cool.
- I didn't say he was Dean cool,
I said he was Jerry,
very (bleep) passionate.
- Alright, (bleep), marry, kill.
Dean, Jerry, Avery.
- None of them, Mike.
- Who the hell's Mike?
- Are you kidding me?
How did this guy get a
license to be a lawyer?
- [Both] Are you kidding me?
- Wait, but there are two more episodes.
- What? How?
- I don't know.
- Maybe something good happens to them?
- That's it?
- That's it.
Maybe we could...
- Go outside?
- No, no.
Maybe we could, we could,
we could rewatch The Jinx.
- Yeah.
- The Jinx?
- Yeah, let's do that.
- Let's just binge watch.
It's only eight hours, six hours,
we could do that tonight.
- Let's do it.